i always start with the ending so
no
i don't start writing until i have the
ending
how did you learn to write stories
how did i learn to write stories wow um
you know you start off with
um
the whole save the cat situation so
here's a funny it's not funny but here's
a story um
so a friend of mine who actually is
uh a director
um
he i used to choreograph a show called
it's always sunny in philadelphia
and he was the director of those
episodes that i choreographed and now he
went ahead and did one division all the
episodes of wand division like he's in
game of thrones he's like he's huge now
and so i said hey look i want to
actually learn how to how to write you
know what would you suggest
he was the one who said save the cat so
of course we all
you know we're all told save the cat so
started off with save the cat initially
at the same time i was going to school
so i learned writing through that and
that was not save the cab but it's
basically the same beats
um
so those that's how i started writing
and then i went ahead and uh worked with
pilaria alessandra uh who's like a
mentor of mine and uh i went and took
her clash as a you know this um um she
has a book that that she has as well
regarding screenwriting and i've taken
her course in many of her courses i've
looked at film courage i've looked at
other um
uh
videos regarding you know structure and
what have you and so
i think when you look at my writing it's
changed over time it's evolved
it was it was very save the cat at first
and then i kind of just you know slowly
but surely just went down to okay what
exactly do i need to what are the basic
elements that i need and so i kind of
just focus on five main things
um
knowing that in there are things in
between these five things that i need to
have i need to have conflict obviously
which helps to
to change your protagonist over time and
so i always start with the ending
of so initially i come with an idea okay
there's an idea for something that i
want to write great what do i want to
say what's the theme so i go there first
if i can i come up with a log line
and i kind of use that as my north star
that way i remember okay it's always
about this moment that may change over
time
then i go ahead and i do the ending
how do i want this character to end by
the ending of this
tv show
pilot or movie what i want to have them
in and then i start them the exact
opposite in the very beginning so i have
two pieces that i need
i know i need an exciting incident what
sets them off on their journey you know
um they get this letter that came out of
the blue um they open the door and
there's a dead body you know something
that happens that's the exciting
incident so that's that's there then i
need a midpoint
some kind of twist that happens in the
middle and then i need an all this loss
moment
so i have those five points and then
from there i go ahead and i i start
making beats so i knowing that i need to
get to these five points
then i begin to create a beat sheet and
the beat sheet is literally just
okay then this happens and then this
happens and then this happens and they
meet this person then this happens and
it's blo it's everything there's nothing
that's off limits and a lot of it
doesn't get used but some of it does
and then once i have an idea of through
the beats i begin to massage the beats
to make sure that it makes sense that
based upon these beats or these scenes
this character is changing and they're
making decisions and there's conflict
and who's con you know who's creating
the conflict and i start i i start
coming up with characters that can help
to drive this protagonist one way or the
other um
to get to these five main main points
and then after that's done and then i
create an outline and my outlines are
very detailed um what i typically do
with my outline is i take my beats that
have been approved that i'm gonna go
with
um
and then i i put them on a um
on a uh you know
a word document something like that and
i put down location
exterior interior location day night
underneath that in parentheses i put
down the name of the characters that are
in the scene and then i put down um
you know a summary of what the scene is
about what does each character want
sometimes i want to feel some dialogue
i'll throw in some dialogue in there
that will be temporary dialogue that
i'll change later on but just get an
idea of what it is
and i do that for all the beats
until i'm done with the whole thing and
when i'm done
then i copy this and i paste it into
final draft
and now i have my outline
and the reason why i know not everybody
uses it online but
there are going to be times when you are
on a paid project they're going to ask
you for an outline
and so it's good to it's a good habit to
develop the habit of outlining because
sometimes you'll have to that's part of
your deliverable
to a network um that you need to have an
outline
so once that's done now it's like it's
like 15 to 20 pages
and when i have that i'm go that's why
it takes me such a short amount of time
to
to write because at that point it's just
dialogue at that point i know what the
characters want i know who's in the
character you know i know who's in the
scene
i know the location i know it's day or
night i've done all the hard work now
it's just about let's go have fun let's
write how how do we get there in the
scene how does you know
how does steve you know get upset at
harry is she hiding something from him
are there any and i just do a first
vomit draft blah get everything done
um
for me it takes about two weeks to once
everything's outlined it takes about two
weeks to finish a feature film my first
draft
then i put it away for like a day
and i always at the end of whenever i
finish writing my first draft i always
drink something a little alcohol um and
i will go eat something something like
you know spend some money and go just
like celebratory like whoo the hard
part's done
then i'll go back after a day and i'll
start looking at it and i'll go back
into each of these scenes and i make
sure like is there are there nuances in
there am i did i write too much is there
too many words can we because i'm a
director i also look at you know ways
that i can visually look and tell the
story without words you know i would
much rather do that kind of stuff
and i go back and i and i do that for
every single scene and that takes me
about a week to do
and then after that
i go ahead and give my script to my
brother
who is who has learned
through
your website
through me teaching him he's learned he
and he he works in aerospace
we've actually written two scripts
together over 2020 we did two feature
films that we wrote together because
he's gotten the hang of storytelling
um
i give it to him he gives me some notes
back
things that he because he's logical
so he gives me the this doesn't make
sense how did he get here like
like like character wise like why is he
so upset what happened before to get him
to this point
so i'll go back and maybe add a few
extra scenes or whatever to to earn
why we are at this point in the in the
character's behavior
then i'll give it to a friend of mine
that's a woman
uh and she uh she's an actress
but she also writes
and because i like to get a woman's
point of view about certain things
especially because a lot of my
characters are women and i want to get
somebody else's point of view that's you
know not a male um in reference to how
this
person is behaving and she'll give me
the real skinny like i told her like
don't play with me like give me the
truth and she'll tell me like we would
never do this or this is what would
happen and so i can now go back and i
can make that right and then i'll give
it to my management team and they'll
give me notes and they'll tear it apart
and then we'll get that cleaned up and
then after that that's when i can you
know
take it out and go and go shopping with
it
so that's my process in a nutshell
regarding how i start from the very
beginning of an idea which you know
ideas come from everywhere um
we've had discussions and we literally
just thought of an idea for a christmas
movie you know what i'm saying like it
comes from anywhere just like talking to
people
noticing things like as a writer you
have to do that now like nothing's off
limits right
um anybody tells you something it's like
then you know it may end up in the
script somewhere just letting you know
um
and they understand that
so two weeks to finish a feature like
the first draft of a feature script and
how does that break down per day or are
you doing more in one day than another
yeah so i have a mandate that i do 15
pages per day and that's my mandate no
matter how long it takes
so i'm i'll
i won't go straight through i'll take
breaks i'll go get some food i'll get
lunch and other kind of stuff but it's
like 15 pages a day and it goes back to
that mantra about
you may be a better writer than me you
may be a director than me but you will
not outwork me and that's kind of like
my thing it's like i'm i'm putting in
the work and so i treat it like a
nine-to-five job like i'm clocking in
and so it's like no
i have you know eight to 12 hours that
i'm dedicating towards these these 15
pages now there's been times when i've
gotten 12 hours and i've only done 10
pages it's like okay i you know i'm
taking the l on this one i can't go
anymore i'm too tired blah blah so
as a result you know you kind of leave
that alone and you kind of come back the
next day knowing you owe for the those
those five pages um but for the most
part that's that's the way i do it and
and that's what allows me to knock
things out so fast so a feature film i
get it done in two weeks the first draft
and then
a one hour uh episode
of a tv show i'll get that done in a
week
it sounds like you honor a lot of
commitments for yourself with writing
like you said you have these amounts of
pages that you do but then also once you
finish you put it away for one day and
then you go and you kind of do this
mental or a real celebration yeah so
you're keeping your word like you're
becoming your own boss with yourself
yeah so it's very interesting yeah
rewarding yourself yeah i totally agree
i i think you have to do that
it's so hard to sit down and just write
it is the most
it's the most amazing
and most horrible thing you know because
it can be boring
um
i think one one benefit that i have
because as a director i like to like
look at okay how would i shoot this when
i'm writing it which i shouldn't do but
i can't help it
so i will you know i put a lot of action
in my scenes um
not necessarily like fighting action but
like
i give my character something to do and
that's also because i'm a choreographer
you know i don't when i when i stage my
my scenes i usually will give the
character something in their hand or
they'll start someplace doing something
because
the actors love
to be busy they don't want to just stand
there and just be talking heads like
give me something and then
when you're writing think about i'm
always thinking about okay whatever
they're doing what does that tell me
about who they are as a human being as a
person
or
about this moment like are they you know
is their knee going up and down are they
you know what's the situation here
because that visual situation tells me
what they're experiencing
so i try to marry all that stuff
together
in a way that tells a story not only
through words but also through actions
and are you ever tempted when you can't
figure out the ending to say well for
this one i'm just going to start writing
and i'll figure out this ending later
good question no i always start with the
ending so
no
i don't start writing until i have the
ending like i know
whether the indie's going to be happy or
sad
you know so um
i have a a a script that i wrote
that
uh initially
you see this is this was the interesting
thing the initial ending of the script
was a sad ending
as a mother
um
she dies in the end
and and that's how i wrote it and so the
very beginning
i knew i needed to make her um
well let me go back it's a mother who
dies but she dies sacrificing herself
for her family
so
for her to reach that arc
how does she have to be in the very
beginning
she has to be the type of mother that
doesn't sacrifice that's selfish
and that's how we start the story so
that that way to me if i know this and
this
i know we're gonna have an arc
now the question is how do we earn
getting her there
you know you know
if she's gonna sacrifice herself in the
end in the very beginning she has to be
selfish well let's say you're being
selfish in the very beginning how do we
how do we show that
and so that's how we get into the story
and that's how i do all my scripts
that's how i started i started with the
ending because it's easier for me to to
understand the beginning and
typically my openings usually are very
dynamic my openings are like there is
some something going on and it pulls you
right in so i'm really good with my
openings because i know how i'm going to
end it
and you keep that log line you said it's
kind of like your north star yeah yeah
which is again overall what is the story
about what's what am i trying to say
what's the theme or um you know
it also kind of tells you a little bit
about
about the arc as well you know um a
self-centered mother just throwing out
an idea you know a self-centered mother
a mother deals with family tragedy um
from her from her from her past and as a
result you know
um
you know s saves her family from
you know something um
that log line reminds me of what this is
and everything that i write in between
there
midpoint
all is loss
you know clothes are the ending
it reminds me of what i need to be doing
with this character and all the all the
characters that come into her life are
going to be pulling her one way or the
other either to stay
to stay um uh uh selfish or to not be
selfish like all the character's gonna
be pulling her back and forth one way or
the other whether it's her husband her
kids her boss
you know
yeah
and the dialogue that you write does
that
it must vary then for the projects if
you're going to do a christmas movie
it's going to be cleaner dialogue it's
going to be
um
maybe more on the nose yeah um
ooh that's a very good point um
that's where i do try to buck the system
a little bit i try not to be so on the
nose even with those situations
where it's
it's pretty much a pain by numbers
story
in the sense that we know what a
christmas movie usually entails
um
i try to find moments of nuance
especially when when there's emotional
moments
so i wrote so for example um
a stone cold christmas you know there is
there's some dialogue back and forth
between uh the woman played by dimitri
mckinney and her her
ex-boyfriend or this guy that she's a
date
and
they are talking about the past about
things that happen but i i do try to
hold back some things and to let
this
the face of the characters explain what
happened
i do try to do that so even with
even with a christmas movie
there's moments that you can do that
maybe not a lot of moments but there's a
few moments that you can actually
find nuanced ways of telling a story
without being on the news
and in that movie it's about sort of a
power driven
woman
who's all about success and you know
christmas is just another day to her and
then she sort of finds the meaning of
christmas
through
her own arc
yeah exactly and you know she
she
she became angry because of
because of a trauma that happened when
she was a child you know she had a kid
she had to give the kid up for adoption
because
because she was a child
and you know she
um
her mother didn't approve
and so she gave this child up
and
come to find out that the assistant that
works for her actually is her her own
child but we don't fight that out into
the third act oh wow spoiler alert um
so yeah so this whole time she's been
grooming
this girl
and this girl is her her own daughter
she never knew that oh wow until the
very end so yeah there's there's a nice
little emotional arc there they're all
crying and it's it's very weepy and it
you know it's fun it's a fun movie
so it's funny because
that is my way of trying to buck the
system
by having this really cool twist in the
end but i still played within the
sandbox all the same beats are there
there's a kiss at the end there's snow
falls you know we
she's she's she's angry in the beginning
and she's mean at the beginning but by
the end
she's a different person but we started
with the ending where do we want her to
end up we want her to end up finding
love
realizing that this is her daughter and
now we have a happy family in the very
beginning she's alone she's angry
you know she doesn't she has bad she has
bad memories of her childhood
yeah so that's again it's the same rule
even though it's it's in a different
genre and when you got notes on it did
anybody say like oh that's a little
you're talking about you know like an
unwed
unwed you know teen mother or whatever
that might be too taboo for christmas
movie or something thank goodness for uh
the network bounce tv they didn't
feel that
i know for a fact lifetime would not
have gone for that so this network i
felt like i can push them up a little
bit it was their very first it was their
very first um
uh movie of the week
and before that they had like a whole
bunch of like half-hour
comedies and one-hour dramas and the
drama states of sinners is really crazy
so i think they were already groomed to
accept some things even though it was a
christmas movie